since the pandemic hit and the united
states began to pursue loose monetary
policy there's been a lot of talk about
inflation the whole idea is that by
increasing the money supply all that
money is chasing the same set of goods
and that means that the prices have to
rise but one little trick of many
producers across america and the globe
is something called shrink-flation what
they do is they keep prices stable but
they actually put less items in the bag
the box or inside of their product now
normally shrink flation it's something
that people try to label as a conspiracy
theory they try to say that doesn't
happen but this morning we had the
pepsico cfo on national television
admitting yes sometimes they do take
less chips and put it in a bag and salt
you for the same price now this isn't
shocking but it's important to
understand exactly what they're saying
here here is mr johnston talking about
shrink flation and admitting that
pepsico does it
you know and i've been kidding all
morning long about how you know because
you always tell us this you know content
contents may have settled during during
packaging are you giving me le and i'm
not complaining you give me fewer
doritos it's good for you it's good for
me it's good for everybody i understand
i don't need as many as come in a big
bag
what's the average
either tell me how how much you've
raised prices on these things
to keep up with inflation or how much
you've cut down on what's in the what's
the average
packaging in terms of whether it's less
than it was a year ago there are times
when we'll take ships out of the bag
instead of taking pricing up there's no
denying that there's no doubt about it
there's other times when we'll actually
increase the number of chips in the bag
and we may take pricing up a little bit
along with that so what we try to do is
say how are consumers actually using
that package and we actually studied
this stuff and try to figure out okay
based on that what's the right size of
the bag we move them around all the time
that's something that that happens
frequently for the most part consumers
seem to be very happy with it you know
we we still see volumes going up we
still can't see the number of occasions
going up so people want to want to buy
our product more and more now of course
i'm not surprised that they're engaging
in shrink-flation everyone can see that
there's less items in the bag but what i
do think is interesting is that they
also talk about sometimes they put more
chips in the bag but at the end of the
day they believe that the consumer is
happy i would love to see the metrics on
how they measure what is the consumer
happiness with how many chips are in a
bag everyone i've ever talked to they
always talk about there's too much air
and not enough chips i've never had
someone say man i love these chips
because they fill the bag all the way to
the top now shrink-flation is just
another product of what happens when you
have too much money sloshing around in
an economy but not enough supply
increasing to keep up
at the end of the day whether it's
inflation or shrink-flation the average
consumer is taking a beating
we have to get this problem under
control some of it is directly
attributed to the monetary policy some
of it is supply chain disruptions and
some of it is just the psychology in the
market as people prepare for worse
economic times
shrink flation and inflation they go
hand in hand and now we have the cfo one
of the largest companies in the world
admitting yes they do it but don't worry
the consumer loves it